also ich bin aus Ludwigshafen ich wohne
da schon viele Jahre und ein Konzern ob
man ihn mag oder nicht wie die BASF
bringt natürlich Wohlstand und
Arbeitsplätze und
die Sanktionen die stattgefunden haben
auch diese exorbitanten Gas und
Energiepreise haben jetzt bei BASF
zugeschlagen mit 2,2 Milliarden
Zusatzkosten das muss man sich einfach
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen was das
für für eine Summe ist dass es Wucher
nach dem Völkerrechts darf man einem
Volk die Existenzgrundlage nicht in 10
das ist Artikel 1 Absatz 2 Satz 2 im
icscr und in iccbr und ich sehe schon
seit Monaten zu wie immer wieder die
Pleitewelle per Titel Überschrift und
per Schlagzeilen kommt und sehe diese
Entspanntheit im Bundestag kein Mensch
spricht darüber in Herr Habig sagt naja
wenn die Produktion wir haben es ja
gehört wenn die Produktion eingestellt
wird ist das noch lange keine Insolvenz
ich sehe auch schon in dieser Stadt also
in Ludwigshafen und ich denke die ist
repräsentativ viele Industriestädte eine
öde ganz viele Geschäfte haben zugemacht
ein großer Investor hat ein riesen
EInkaufszentrum übernommen aber aus dem
Ausland und der Mittelstand bricht in
sich zusammen Schlaufe Gassi sehe
Rentner die im Müll wählen und Flaschen
suchen um sich ihr ihre schmale Rente zu
verbessern ich sehe eine Flut von
Flüchtlingen in dieser Stadt und ich
glaube das ist repräsentativ ist für die
für die den gesamten Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und ich fordere die Politik
auf mit diesem Wahnsinn aufzuhören weil
das ist eine die und die und die
Industrialisierung die diese
Volkswirtschaft zerstören wird was hat
die Politik denn ihrer Meinung nach in
diesem Fall falsch gemacht woran liegt
das
also die Politik scheint sich immer mehr
für das im Außen zu interessieren als an
das Wohl der eigenen Bevölkerung sie sie
haben eine Sanktionspolitik durchgeführt
die letztendlich zu diesem Chaos geführt
hat viele andere Staaten haben das
offensichtlich nicht die kaufen nämlich
zum Beispiel russisches Gas und
verkaufen es noch Deutschland und zwar
für viel teureres Geld als wir es hätten
so haben können Herr Gaffron Sanktionen
lieber weg als
sanktionsausbildung nicht folgen die
Ursachen für die wir heute ausbaden
liegen ja ganz woanders das heißt also
wenn ich mich so abhängig mache wie die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland von einem
Lieferanten 55% und den Russen von denen
jederzeit Jahren weiß dass sie weder
einen Rechtsstaat sind noch eine nicht
aggressive Außenpolitik betreiben das
konnten sie ja schon sehen bei dem
Annektion von apassion und südostizien
in Georgien das konnten sie sehen bei
der Krim und das sehen wir jetzt wieder
das heißt wir sind bewusst in eine
gefährliche Lage hineingetrieben
oder durch Blindheit und jetzt zahlt
sich das aus ein Land das zu mal aus der
Atomenergie einfach aussteigt ohne ein
Ersatz dafür zu haben ohne die vor gut
drei weil er dürfen ja jetzt
weiterlaufen
Madame Merkel ja da ist der Grundfehler
unseres heutigen Desasters ohne das zu
Ende
das ist nicht so die Kausalitäten sind
ein bisschen anders und ich finde
Auffassung wir hätten auch wenn die
Abhängigkeit von Russland und ich muss
auch ein bisschen was sagen gegen die
regierungscheelte wir haben es immerhin
geschafft dass wir die gastbehälter die
werden Russen verkauft haben gefüllt
haben dieses Land ist nicht taub und
auch Dynamik ich werde mich einfach
dagegen dass wir unsere Land so
runtermachen die Bundesrepublik Tag und
Nacht machen sich Leute Gedanken wie
doch das haben sie gerade gemacht und
das finde ich auch das ist Bild von
Hungernden Rentnern die da irgendwo im
aber das ist doch nicht die
Bundesrepublik waren sie am Flughafen
zum Ferienbeginn 70.000 Leute sind vom
Flughafen Tegel weggeflogen in den
Urlaub aber das ist jetzt nicht der
Ernst ich laufe jeden Tag Gassi mit
meinem Hund sie reden jeden Tag Rentner
die im Müll will und die die ganzen
Hund ja aber damit zu tun
nicht werden
morgens irgendwann mal oder zu Hause und
ich bin in Wien zu Hause und ich bin in
Berlin zu Hause muss ehrlich sagen also
es ist überall einigermaßen in Ordnung
die muss ehrlich sagen man kann immer
noch stolz sein dass man in Deutschland
also es gibt schon viele Viertel in
vielen Städten also wenn ich abends so
durch Neukölln laufe als Gast hier ja
und dann meine Sprache erkennen müssen
wir vielleicht ich bin ja nicht aus
Deutschland über zwei deutsche Mutter
aber aber einen österreichischen Vater
und komme aus Wien also was wir in
Deutschlands auf die Nerven geht ist das
schlechtmachen des eigenen Landes das
ist doch schrecklich aber
es gibt Arme Viertel aber
wenn man jede jede jede jedes
Unternehmen ja das in sich versagt hat
ja und dann einen Anlass nimmt nämlich
die Energieverteilung um irgendetwas zu
machen woanders hinzugehen wo das
übrigens auch nicht viel billiger ist ja
da muss man nämlich sagen bitte schauen
uns aber die Firmen an das ist mein
ernst nehmen Sie die den nehmen Sie den
Hacke für den Hackl Betrieb ja
Toilettenpapier jeder Kauf
Toilettenpapier und plötzlich in der
tolle Person immer kaputt
Deutschland es liegt an den
Energiekosten hier können wir so nicht
mehr erinnern sie doch nach Frankreich
da ist es was weiß ich um einiges
günstiger kaufen russisches Gas z.B es
liegt am Standort Deutschland von vor
Corona und dieser Energie dieser
ukraine-krise haben etliche deutsche
Firmen auch Autokonzerne den Abbau von
100.000 Arbeitsplätzen angekündigt
werden wir im internationalen Wettbewerb
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind das
sind doch alles hausgemacht das
Standorts Deutschland aber es ist doch
nicht okay aber das ist doch nicht okay
in ihrer Praxis merken sie dass das
zugenommen hat dass es eine
Wohlstandsverwahrlosung sozusagen gibt
fühlen sich die Menschen von der Politik
allein gelassen also es gibt natürlich
immer die die tatsächlichen Zahlen es
gibt die gefühlte Wirklichkeit aber ich
muss sagen beides ich würde ich schon
sagen beides hat bei vielen meiner
Patienten schon zu Existenzängsten
geführt und ich ich habe auch
Selbstständige die auch aufgehört haben
ich glaube wir reden halt letztendlich
über eine Entwicklung die nachher kann
ich das auch mit Kofi zusammenbringen
damit zusammenhängen dass wir in
Deutschland uns angewöhnt haben einfach
gegen Sachverstand zu entscheiden
welches die Energie Sache zum Beispiel
sehe ist das jetzt glaube ich so acht
Jahre her da haben die Professoren des
physikalischen Instituts in Heidelberg
eine Stellungnahme zur Energiewende
gebracht da steht genau das drin was
jetzt eingetreten ist und keiner hat
sich dafür interessiert ich habe die
Rhein-Neckar-Zeitung gefragt und
Heidelberg bringt das doch das ist doch
vor der Haustür die Uni ist doch
interessant nein es hat keinen
interessiert waren alle in ihrem waren
waren man kann alles abschalten und mit
Windkraft und erneuerbaren ersetzen
jetzt haben wir halt die Quittung und
das ist jetzt man könnte nur damit
beginnen müssen
die Alternative war natürlich dass man
nach dem Einstellen oder dem Auslaufen
des Atomenergie Bedarf dass man dann
etwas anderes aufbaut damit hat man zu
spät begonnen da hat man nichts gemacht
und das ist das Problem
ausgebauten Fahrstuhl vergessen
dann zeigt aber die Frage ist wie geht's
denn jetzt weiter wird es jetzt ist das
der Anfang vom Ende BASF werden jetzt
weitere Firmen abwandern sind wir auf
einer downwärtsspirale ganz ganz
sicherlich nicht ganz sicherlich nicht
das werden schwierige Möglichkeiten gar
keine Frage es ist verdammt einmal nicht
leichter zu produzieren in den im UK
oder in Frankreich das ist doch alles
eine Irrtum ja natürlich kann man
leichter wir haben da schon einmal
vorher diskutiert darüber in Amerika
produzieren weil dort die Energie Teere
billiger ist weil sie sich selbst
beziehen und selbst herstellen können
aber das alles downwärts geht aber auch
ohne russisches Gas wird es auch ohne
russisches Gas so bleiben wie es ist
oder
unsere Gesellschaft ist stark genug
unsere Kreativität und die Köpfe die
hier sind dieses meistern
und der hier tätigen Kräfte und nicht
dieses marode Russland die das einzige
was sie haben verscheuern ihre Rohstoffe
sonst haben sie nämlich
genau gegen dieser Gaskrise eben die
Unternehmen sagen sie können nicht mehr
produzieren deshalb Menschen entlassen
werden und ähnliches was soll man denn
jetzt machen wir wollen wir das denn
jetzt auf der auf die Schnelle
ausgleichen wer ist da wirklich jetzt
daran Schuld der Gaspreis in der
Zwischenzeit ist in der vor
ukraine-krise das ist und wieso ist aber
so ja also da gibt schon noch mehr zu
klären sie genauso wie beim Benzinpreis
komischerweise steigt der Benzinpreis
immer dann wenn Schulferien sind und
zwar dramatisch sagen ja
digitalismus der hier zum Ausdrucken wer
ist denn Schulter dann dran was sind
denn das für Mechanismen die dahinter
stehen natürlich kapitalistische
Mechanismen marktwirtschaftlicher
Mechanismen die von einer Regierung auch
ein bisschen eingebremst werden muss und
deswegen hat die EU eingeschritten und
wird hoffentlich einschreiten aber das
geht nur für die extreme ich bin im
Gottes Willen kann nicht Kapitalist ja
oder oder kein Anti marktwirtschafter
aber nur alles kann man nicht überladen
in Erhöhung an Strom und und Gaspreisen
nicht mit ganz normalen kapitalistischen
Interessen verbinden das ist
Wahnsinns Preise
nach Ludwigshafen
mit Frau neige spazieren gehen also ich
meine ich glaube schon dass das
erschreckende Bilder teilweise sind und
ich glaube dass ihre Wahrnehmung da
schon auch ein bisschen ich will Ihnen
speziell ist ich will immer etwas sagen
glauben Sie das ist eine elitäre Meinung
ich habe viele Jahre in den USA gelebt
in Detroit ist als Autostadt vor die
Hunde gegangen war wie ein Ghost Town
denn sie heute hinkommen ist eine
prosperierende
it-metropole geworden weil der tüchtige
Menschen die nicht Jammer gejammert
haben sondern gesagt don't talk about it
no problems only solution
ist sie müssen erstmal die Fahrstunde
sie haben Recht aber Sie müssen erstmal
die Flaschen feuern und die Felgen dran
lassen das ist der Punkt
da haben wir gerade so ist
die USA Deutschland das hängt ja noch
mal an irgendein gar kein Gesundheit
Sozialsystem ähnliches wir haben ein
ganz anderes
ganz einfach falsch
wer keine Arbeit haben
aber nie arbeitslos glaube ich da ich
bin Unternehmer ja genau Sache mit der
Pflichtversicherung dort nicht notwendig
braucht man eine Zwangsversicherung und
natürlich weißt du
dagegen
Leute aus Krankenhaus
30% der Amerikaner sind entweder nicht
oder unterversichert und die können
nicht ins Spital gehen und ins
Krankenhaus wir können nichts machen
wollen Sie solche Verhältnisse auch bei
uns also eine Segel bekannte
Fluchtbewegung aus den USA ist mir nicht
bekannt und dass man festzuhalten ja es
hatten Amerikaner hier Asyl beantragt
ich glaube wir werden keinen finden
erstmal um das zu sagen die meisten
Menschen die ich kenne Leben dort sehr
gut und sehr wohl und vor allen Dingen
frei
aber auch die Menschen die sie kennen
und es gibt eben einen großen Anteil
glaube ich an Amerikanern die nicht so
glücklich sind mit ihrer Situation und
sehr gerne eigentlich sozial einer
meiner Musiker ist Amerika Deutschland
Existenzängste sind trotzdem ein Problem
was uns hier begleitet in Deutschland
nicht nur in Amerika auch hier haben sie
und das sind keine Illusionen was
erleben was erleben Sie sie sagen ihnen
und sie haben auch viele Freunde
Bekannte die z.B bei Baska BASF arbeiten
und mal wieder zu dem Beispiel
zurückzukommen was bedeutet das jetzt
für die das ist für die einfachen Horror
das ist eine Katastrophe weil wenn die
einfach ihren Job verlieren ich bin ja
ganze Familien dann dann steht
wer hat denn Lust auf diesen Sozialstaat
indem er sich bei Hartz IV anreißt das
ist doch vollkommen Geld wissen Sie
überhaupt dass wenn Sie ein Haus haben
lassen sie sich zwei Kinder zwei Autos
und 150.000 Vermögen haben Sie Anspruch
auf Bürgergeld das ist die Realität zu
definiert dieser Pflanze unfair
bezeichnet
die Menschen haben Angst es sind sehr
sehr viele die schon ihre Geschäfte auch
geschlossen haben während des lockdowns
die haben das nicht überstanden wie
gesagt ich habe vorhin von diesen
Einkaufsstraßen geredet die sind leer
und jetzt haben sie noch größere Angst
und diese Stadt hat nun mal einfach
dieses Zentrum das ist einfach der
größte einnahmebereich und die BASF ist
vor allen Dingen auch zuständig für
Grundstoffe die Sie weitergeben für
weitere Produktionsketten in der
Umgebung da gibt es ja andere
Unternehmen das heißt es bedrohten
gesamten eine gesamte Region und darüber
hinaus